Life is full of uncertainty.
In many ways, we are both the driver and the
passenger of our lives.
With strong self-discipline, we can make decisions
that allow us to predict and control certain
things on the surface of our life.
Things like what we do for work, where we
live, whom we associate with, and how we choose
to live our daily life.
But even with strong intellect, reason, and
self-discipline, there is still a whole realm
of life that we cannot be sure about.
Possibilities that we can only speculate,
but can never fully control.
Like the chance of falling out of love or
having a friend betray us.
The chance of early death, tragedy, or health
conflicts.
Or the chance that things we hold to be true
end up not being so.
All of which is possible.
And all of which, in general, is out of our
control.
This creates deep conflict because as humans,
control is one of our greatest hungers.
With control comes certainty, and with certainty,
we would no longer have the fear of things
going wrong for us or our loved ones.
But life does not work this way.
More often, life functions on its own terms
within the laws of its own arbitrariness.
So what do we do?
How can we live knowing that behind any corner
could be something that might ruin us?
How can we live with this irrevocable fear?
We cannot eliminate uncertainty, but we CAN
rationalize the fear that stems from it.
In life, one of the only things we have true
heightened control over is our thoughts and
perspectives.
And we must use what we CAN control to override
our fear of what we cannot.
If we wish to overcome fear, we must spotlight
our consciousness and rationality onto it.
We can do this by constantly reminding ourselves
of this; if we live in fear of what may or
may not happen, we will spend our life detached
from reality, suffering from things that do
not even exist.
We will be our own worst enemy, self-inflicting
anxiety with no purpose and taking our self
away from enjoying the present moment, which
would otherwise be precious and untainted.
For example, if we fear that we might become
badly ill or injured from an unforeseen occurrence,
fear will not decrease the chances of becoming
ill or injured, but what it WILL do is create
unnecessary suffering.
And if we do, by some unfortunate circumstances
become ill or injured, we would have wasted
the portion of our life when we were healthy,
living with the mental consequences of being
unhealthy.
And therefore, fearing uncontrollable concepts
of the future simply does not make any rational
sense.
It only brings unnecessary anxiety about that
which does not exist, and takes us away from
enjoying that which does.
Uncertainty is not something to be afraid
of.
It cuts both ways.
If it is possible that unforeseen negative
things can happen in life, then it is also
possible that unforeseen positive things can
happen to us in life.
And it is this concept of randomness and unpredictability
that keeps life exciting.
The only thing we can do in life is try our
best to enjoy our time in spite of fear, so
if our fears do come true, at least we enjoyed
ourselves before
the storm.